welcome everyone
my name is tanya i'm your moderator for
this session
today's workshop is working with data in
a connected world the power of graph
data science with dr claire sullivan
hi and welcome claire
i'll just give a i'll just give a short
introduction
claire has a doctorate degree in nuclear
engineering from the university of
michigan
afterwards she started her career in
nuclear emergency response and also
worked in the federal government before
returning to academic research in 2012
as an assistant professor
and there she focused more on machine
learning and
afterwards also worked as github as a
machine learning engineer and just this
year joined neo4j as a graph data
science advocate
she also founded a company laneige
analytics
who
provides data science expertise to the
skiing industry furthermore she has
authored several book chapters
peer-reviewed papers and conference
papers and received some awards for her
impressive impressive achievement
impressive achievements
claire thank you for being with us and
the stage is yours
all right well um first i just want to
say thank you tanya and the i want to
thank the organizers of pi data global
i'm really excited to be here
so good morning good afternoon good
evening wherever i might be happening to
talk to you from and um today we're
going to be talking about working with
connected data and the power of graph
data science and um i want to mention um
as you know we have the slack channel
set up for the tutorials
this is probably where i'm going to be
able to find most of you given our zoom
challenges so if you could uh take your
questions to that channel
and that's where
where we'll be doing things this slide i
am going to be putting up several times
during our workshop today so
um you'll also notice at the bottom is
the github repo
for this tutorial so um we'll be working
with that repo today there's a lot of
resources in there and i will say yes
including the slides that seems to be
one of the biggest questions uh that we
get in these online uh conferences so um
and if you want to get a link to that
repo it's also in the channel for
today's tutorial
so first things first i like to get an
idea of who all uh is in the audience
today so if you could maybe go to that
channel now
and i have two survey questions that
will respond to with emojis and the
first one is
just kind of i'm curious where you're at
in your data science journey and you
know when i know that answer
it really helps me to to kind of figure
out how to uh present the material on
the fly and then the second one is what
you what is your current knowledge of
graphs we're going to be working with
network graphs today um so these are
good things to know so i'm just going to
give you know a minute here for
everybody to
to go in
pick an emoji any emoji
so the uh i am not a data scientist but
i work with them that could be data
engineers that could be in for folks
that could be uh business folks who are
on the receiving end of the results data
scientists produce
so
maybe 15 more seconds on this one
okay let's move on we've already done
our survey thing here and feel free to
keep filling that out
excuse me so by the end of this tutorial
we're going to be able to understand
relative graph data science theory you
know so we've got to understand a little
bit of graph theory we're not going to
spend a huge amount of time there but
but hopefully you get enough feel for it
we'll learn how to import a graph from a
csv file into a graph database now the
thing i'm going to say about that we're
going to be using neo4j as the graph
database it's free it's easy to stand up
but a lot of what i'm talking about
today doesn't actually need to be done
within neo4j there's there's functions
out there that can achieve a lot of what
we're looking to do
in different python packages like
network x different graph databases i'm
using this one just for simplicity
we're going to create some simple
machine learning models based on
traditional machine learning approaches
and then we're going to compare them to
how they work in um in a graph context
and then we're going to use those models
to understand the results of those two
types of embeddings using some pretty
common techniques and python packages so
what are we going to do today
specifically
we're going to talk about why graphs why
not just use sql this is one of the most
common questions i get is hey i can do
queries in sql why do i need to learn
this whole new method of querying um so
we'll talk a bit about that um how do i
know if i have a graphy problem graphene
in quotes um it's you know a lot of
people don't realize it but the problems
that they're looking to solve in data
science actually would be much easier to
solve with a graph um we're going to do
just a really quick introduction to
graph theory and then we're going to get
right into graph machine learning and
dive into some code feel free to code
along if you just want to watch that's
fine too whatever
whatever floats your boat
and then we'll have a brief wrap up
reminder again here's the slack channel
this is where we'll be taking all of our
questions and
here is the github repository again that
repository is linked within the slack
channel for this workshop
okay and the slides are in the
repository
so i like to start
workshops and tutorials with what i call
two key concepts and what that means is
if you take nothing else away from this
tutorial these are the two things that i
hope you can you take away the first
is it it can be really good for us to
break this assumption that individual
data points are independent
that's kind of one of the fundamentals
if you think about it about data science
you know we have columnar data where we
have rows and there's columns associated
with those rows and we assume no
relationship between those rows as we
make our models but today we're going to
break that
because
we know in certain contexts there are
relationships between rows and i'll give
you examples of that as we go along here
second
modeling these relationships uh can not
always but can result in models and
signals that are less noisy and more
accurate so i'll show you examples of
that as we go through the coding portion
but those are the two key things that
i'd like you to take away
okay
so now we're going to dive into the
graph theory portion of today what is a
graph well simply put it's
things connected to other things so
these could be people connected to other
people they could be network routers
this router goes to that router they
could be supply chains um
this
shipment is going to this location
so really it's any any bit of data
connected to any other bit of data and
they appear graphs appear in all kinds
of places obviously social networks um
but internet routing maps and wayfinding
you know we can say that this city is
connected to this other city by this
freeway um so
we can do shortest path and efficient
paths just by you know this is what
google does when you say hey what's the
most what's the quickest way to get me
from point a to point b um
recommendation systems a lot of i when i
was at github we created a
recommendation system that was not at
all built on graphs but in fact it can
be much more efficient to do it with
graphs
search knowledge graphs question
answering systems think about alexa siri
google
google search is based off of graphs and
we'll talk about that one specifically
in a bit
okay
why why would we do this why why are we
going to go down this path and add what
we might think of as more complexity um
this here is just a figure that i took
from kaggle this was a kaggle challenge
a while back trying to predict churn and
you know you've got columns and rows and
we've got information about each of
those rows which corresponds to a person
and we're trying to predict that column
all the way on the right whether the
person
exited from the company
and
we've got information like what country
they're in what their gender is their
age etc
and that's all well and good but let's
say we knew that two of these people
were friends
okay
so let's let's look at this and maybe a
social graph context a social graph
around barack obama okay and barack
obama is friended with different people
such as michelle obama um nancy pelosi
joe biden um maybe indirectly to mitch
mcconnell who knows um
but let's we we know that he has a
strong connection between himself and
his wife michelle
now let's say michelle decides she
doesn't like this social media platform
okay so she's gonna get off
well
what then do we think is the probability
that barack obama will leave that social
media platform so instead of having
these two rows one representing each of
those two people we see that there's a
connection here and that
the probability of barack obama turning
from this social network increases
because michelle obama did okay
um so here's another one a
recommendation engine um and i like to
tell this story i recently built my
house um not me personally my general
contractor did but
um i'm talking to you from high in the
mountains of colorado i'm at 10 200 feet
or 3 100 meters pick your unit of choice
and um when we were building the house
we were going to a big box hardware
store somewhat regularly and they could
learn things about my purchasing habits
such as well claire bought a whole bunch
of wood and nails maybe that means
claire's building a house and then we
see that claire bought windows and
siding okay now we're getting pretty
sure that claire's building a house so
we're going to start recommending things
for her that she could buy along the
different stages of building a house
maybe wiring and plumbing parts lighting
things like that well it turns out that
one of the things that was recommended
to me was a mailbox
okay i didn't buy the mailbox
and you know i so that meant i stopped
following this pattern of what users do
when you know customers do when they're
building a house the question is why you
know obviously i need to get my mail
however what this hardware store
neglected to realize was that where i
live doesn't actually have mail service
i have to use a post office box in town
and so had they looked at all of my
neighbors within my subdivision my
geographic vicinity i have connections
to these neighbors and none of them
bought
mailboxes either now this is a true
story none of the people in my county
own have mail service and yet this big
box store has a whole shelf in a row
that's dedicated to mailboxes and that
shelf is collecting dust so they spent a
lot of money stocking their shelves with
something that had they just looked at
the relationships among people within my
area to realize none of us had bought
machine or bought mailboxes might have
saved them some money
okay
let's move on
i'd like to just remind you here that we
are doing questions within the slack
channel the slack channel is called
working with data in a connected world
the power of graph data science
okay so how do i know if i have a
so-called graphy problem that's the
technical term graphy um there's a rule
of thumb that i like to tell people and
that is if you are doing something in
sql
and you have more than a couple joins
maybe you're doing it in pandas whatever
but you have more than a couple joins so
you're joining on a few different tables
or several different tables um this is a
hint that you have a graphy problem now
um paco nathan gave a great talk
yesterday and he was showing these
really complicated joins on you know sql
tables with their schema and whatnot and
it's really hard to intuitively
understand what's going on there by
looking at it so if you have more than a
couple sql joins so let's play oh yeah
we're going to play a game here we're
going to play will it graph
okay will it graph is do i have a graphy
problem here um
for those of you familiar with the will
it blend uh web
youtube channel so a lot of us many of
us are familiar with the traditional
mnist challenge
it's a neural network challenge where we
look at handwritten digits and images
and we try to predict what number they
are
so will it graph well
the answer is yes
when you're talking about images
assuming that you're not talking about
random noise in an image
the pixels nearby other pixels have a
relationship to them there's some
continuity there and that relationship
can be modeled with the graph
okay let's look at another one here
facial recognition will it graph well if
you think about it faces are connected
as well the different points the
different geographical points along your
face are connected and that can be
modeled with a graph
natural language processing we're
actually going to do some natural
basic nlp later today
will it graph well the answer is yes
there are relationships between words
words are connected to other words
through things like verbs and
you know how
adjectives describe words so there is a
connection we can do natural language
processing with a graph
um so let's hit some basic graph theory
now that we've seen what we can graph
let's look at how we can graph it um
first we're going to talk about directed
versus undirected versus weighted graphs
now what i'm showing here on the left is
an undirected graph think of facebook or
meta or whatever they changed its name
to yesterday um i'm gonna call it
facebook so think about facebook where
you're friended with other people there
is there is no relationship there if
you're friended with them they're
required to be friended with you that's
how that social media platform works um
i can have different node types um so my
note we call those circles nodes we call
the lines between them relationships or
edges nodes are sometimes called
vertices um so my nodes are the circles
and maybe my different node types maybe
blue corresponds to people and
green corresponds to
groups on facebook and maybe red
corresponds to organizations or
something like this so um
that's that's nodes
and relationships now here we've now
changed to a directed graph where we
don't have to have two people friended
together like facebook so twitter is
more of an example of this i can follow
somebody on twitter but they don't have
to follow me back okay now um we also
can add this concept concept in called a
weighted graph and what the weights do
is they indicate the strength of
connection between my nodes so a
stronger connection would have a higher
weight for example you see the blue node
in the center and the blue node at
roughly one o'clock um and that has a
really strong connection it might
indicate for instance how many times
those two people communicate with each
other or in the opposite sense it could
indicate say route finding this these
two nodes are going to take 10 minutes
to get to each other or let's like
actually let's look at the blue node and
the two red nodes
i can go
to my lower red node either directly
which will take me eight minutes or i
can go to the upper red node six plus
one is seven so it'd actually be faster
to go that way
okay monopartite versus bipartite
what this means is
how many different node types do i have
in my graph so on the graph on the left
i have people which are shown as dark
blue and i have tv shows which are shown
as light blue and this is a weighted
graph um so this is who views which tv
show um
you know and then the weights here in
this particular figure indicate the
number of episodes that that person has
watched
um
so that's a bipartite graph now we can
convert that through graph modeling into
a mono part type graph where we have all
of the same type of nodes
and in this case what we've done is
we've looked at how many shows do two
people have in common so for instance
we've got ann and bev and they have one
show in common and that would be
farscape as you can see on the left we
have bev and evan who have two shows in
common so they have let's see
farscape
uh i don't see where the second one is
oh firefly of course um so
that's the difference between a
monopartite and a bipartite graph and i
want to call your attention to this book
that's highlighted in red this book
these figures actually come from this
book and this book describes
all of the different types of graph
theory we're only barely scratching the
surface today but this is a great book
it goes into graph algorithms and it
does it in two different places apache
spark and neo4j apache spark has some
libraries graph frames being one of them
uh graphics being another one so you can
see how you would do these uh different
graph algorithms in both platforms if
that's of interest to you
okay and then um here's just creating a
projection of just the television shows
how many um the weights are how many
active viewers and
active views do they have between the
two of them so um
just uh graph modeling is a whole art
unto itself there's all kinds of videos
out there on youtube and whatnot on how
to do it now why does this work why why
can we do
math on a graph because we can turn a
graph into all kinds of different
mathematical constructs such as an
adjacency matrix the adjacency matrix
for the graph that you see here on the
left is shown on the right and what i
have is rows and columns where i'm
showing the relationships between
two nodes for example let's go to
row a or
column a row b so we see the one there
indicates that there is a relationship
of going from b
the the row to the column a um you could
think of this in a directed
an undirected context and what you would
have is something that's symmetric about
the diagonal
so we can do this also
looking at degree how many degrees does
each node have which means how many
things how many relationships coming in
and out of it does that node have now we
could talk about in degree in degrees
just how many nodes are coming in out
degree how many nodes are going out so
we can see that a here if you were to
count the number of arrows associated
with a you get eight so i have a
diagonal matrix here showing the degree
of each of the nodes
okay now what can we do with these
things well we could look at degree
centrality these are different metrics
here that i'm showing of which
which nodes here are the most important
in the graph and there's all kinds of
different ways that you can measure that
if you go online and look for a
youtube series called bite-sized neo4j
for data scientists this is a little
video series that i've done and my most
recent episode which was released
yesterday talks all about centrality
calculation so degree centrality
which nodes have the most
relationships associated with them and
that in this case would be a because
it's got the most arrows coming in and
out between this centrality now this is
a little different between the
centrality i like to explain and think
about your office space and you've got
the big boss person and you want to talk
to the big boss person well one way you
could do it is you could kind of do this
circuitous route talking to this friend
that friend who maybe plays tennis with
the big boss person but that's not the
most efficient way to do it the most
efficient way would be to go to the
administrative assistant of the big boss
person everybody goes to that person
that person is the gatekeeper to the big
boss person and probably a lot of other
boss people within your office so that
person we have we say has highest
betweenness centrality because they're
the bridge between other nodes um and
then there's this thing called page rank
and pagerank is the algorithm that was
made famous by larry page and it was the
basis for early on google so what we
look at this was done for web pages
linking to other web pages and we
identified or larry page did
which web pages were the most important
by what it linked what linked to them
now you'll see here the yellow node and
that yellow node is large and that size
is going to indicate large page rank in
this case and the yellow node has a
large page rank because lots of other
nodes link to it unlike say those green
nodes on the bottom right there's not
they link to some things but nothing
links to them so they're not very
important now you have the red node on
the upper right it doesn't have a lot of
arrows coming in and out of it but why
is it so big well it's so big because
that really big yellow node linked to it
so an important node linked to it
therefore its page rank is high so
that's pagerank
um community detection is a common thing
that we can do within graphs um it's
it's pretty cool we can look at uh
communities in all kinds of different
ways like you could say okay well i've
got this cluster here of nodes that are
all linking together and not a lot of
nodes linking to this other cluster
which is all densely connected um we can
look at label propagation there's all
kinds of ways that we could do community
detection
and it's um it's based on the math
within the graph
so um
let's talk a little bit um i've just
been going to quickly pause and remind
people that if you have questions please
bring them into the slack channel the
slack channel is called working with
data in a connected world the power of
graph data science probably easiest just
to find just to do a search and slack on
channels type in working and it will
come up so
um let's move along now
we know within traditional data science
we've got
data that's represented in ones and
zeros or
floats and and the whole idea here is
that we're converting say a person
within our data set to a list of things
we convert our goal is to convert
convert things to numbers um think about
natural language processing we have
sentences we do
um
word to vect on these sentences or um
you know any number of tf idf we're
we're converting a sentence into a
string of number or a list of numbers
that those things require require
sequential understanding of our data
this word this word this word and then
that word but what is sequence in a
graph there is no direction with a graph
so what we have to do with graph
embeddings which we will do today is we
are going to do things like hop randomly
around our graph okay um and in that way
it's kind of uh very similar to how you
do know to vec where you hop around a
sentence
and you assemble your vector or your
embedding that way by looking at the
sequence to sequence patterns of words
here in this case our sequence to
sequence is going to be a randomized
pattern moving around our graph okay
so
um this is just how we're going to turn
a graph into numbers and then we can use
those numbers
in any of our traditional machine
learning approaches
a couple things that we learn uh when we
do this there's two different ways that
you could create graph embeddings
transductive versus inductive now
transductive means that every time i put
a new node into my graph i need to
retrain my embeddings versus inductive
means that i can put my node in there
and i don't have to retrain as you can
imagine inductive takes longer to
generate an embedding as transductive
does
we do a lot of matrix factorization when
we create these embeddings but that's
why they can be efficient is because all
we're doing is matrix math we're going
to be talking today about an algorithm
called fast rp fast random projection so
this is all it is is matrix
multiplication i'm multiplying my
adjacency matrix by my degree matrix and
doing some weighting and it's it all
comes out um
so and then there are other methods
based on neural networks to create these
embeddings a lot of times you have those
behind you know under the hood you don't
see them but they're there okay so then
if you look at the right our goal is to
take that high dimensional non-euclidean
space and just create a row
of numbers and embedding just like any
other embedding that we would use in
machine learning
okay now what can we do with those
embeddings well like i said all of the
same machine learning algorithms what
we're going to do is we're going to dump
them just into basic scikit-learn and
we're going to do some basic
classification
you could do binary classification
multi-class multi-label whatever floats
your boat
we can do regression regression can do
things like
well i'll get to in a minute link
prediction clustering i talked about
different clustering earlier levine
clustering and all of that so we can we
can do clustering think k n or something
like that just based on those embeddings
especially useful if we don't have
labels for them today the data we're
going to work with does have labels so
we're going to hopefully make that a bit
easy on ourselves
dimensionality reduction just like you
can have a high dimensional space with
your other embeddings word embeddings
whatever you can drop that
dimensionality of those embeddings
through something like principle
component analysis or t-distributed
stochastic
tsme
forgot the acronym okay but you can do
that
also with graph embeddings um similarity
very common thing that we would do with
graph embeddings what which node is most
similar to which other node that could
be used in something like
doing a recommendation engine well
tanya and claire might be very similar
together why because their cosine the
cosine between their two embeddings is
is small
or as large
so my cosine being
closer to one means that those two nodes
are most similar to each other so same
thing as we would do with other vector
embeddings in our other traditional
machine learning and our row column
approach
um and then um
we can do some things that are unique to
graphs for example link prediction um
let's say i have two people in my social
media or my social network
what's the probability that they're
friends so like you go on to facebook
and they recommend friends to you well
the algorithm that's behind the scenes
there is link prediction so i can use my
graph embeddings to predict a
probability that those people might be
interested in linking up and then sub
graph or subgraph level structural
similarity
this one a good example is you can use
molecules molecules are graphs okay and
so you know maybe think of a big
complicated one like dna well
what structural similarity do i have
just in this small part of that dna
molecule
to to say oh you know here's a gene
variant that's similar to this other
gene variant or you know i've got two
different bits of dna this gene here is
the same as that gene there so that's
not something that would be very easy to
do in traditional machine learning
okay so we're going to do some coding
now
um
let me just go right here i'm going to
remind you that we're taking questions
within the slack channel i am having a
difficult time making zoom work zoom
does not play well with linux which is
what i use
so um
let's let's take our questions to this
particular slack channel
this is the repository for what we're
doing today that repository is linked in
the slack channel um so yeah
let's talk about the data set we're
going to use as we get to coding here
this data set is called the core data
set it's a pretty common
graph
data set it's looking at citations
specifically scientific publications
within data science in this data set
there are 2708
publications and they fall into seven
different classes and
so that means we have a multi-class
problem somebody's gone through and hand
labeled these things
in that data set there are
5429 citation relationships and those
are the things that we're going to use
for our graph portion of the problem but
we're also going to do this as
traditional machine learning meaning
we're going to look at some data that is
that comes with this data set somebody
created some
word vectors associated with the
abstract um so they did some sort of nlp
process and they one hot encoded the
words um to a dictionary of
1433 words now i don't have access to
that dictionary so we just kind of have
to go with the vectors that they have
provided in this database and what we
have here on the bottom is a graph model
now i've received a question what is one
hot well when we have a dictionary let's
say we have the word
machine
learning
okay now if the words machine if the
word machine is present i give it a one
in the spot for machine um in in my
vector now let's say the word learning
is not present so learning corresponds
to this column it gets a zero
um and so in that way they've created
this dictionary to say is this word
present is this word present is this
word present
so that's just the one hot encoding
to create these vectors so what we wind
up with
each paper is going to have an id
associated with it which is just an
integer we don't get the paper titles or
anything like that in this data set and
then it has a subject the subject is
that class that i had before so we're
going to see things like neural networks
reinforcement learning theory things
like that as these classes now a paper
the relationship between one paper and
another paper is a citation so um you
know i've written a lot of uh scientific
papers before and like i'll cite you
know here's the canonical work in this
field okay so that's the relationship
that we're going to use now i like this
data set for this class because it
allows us to do both traditional machine
learning and
graph machine learning but there's tons
and tons of other data sets out there
you'll find though that a lot of graph
papers a lot of graph theory papers use
this quora data set as kind of their
benchmark
okay
if you would like to code along today
we're going to be using google collab um
and i'll show you how to get it set up
here in a minute um just a nice
platform very similar jupiter notebooks
if you've never used it i'll show you
how and we're also going to be creating
a free graph database um on what we call
the neo4j sandbox
a lot of uh graph databases out there
they provide you know a free
free way to interact with it
this is the one we're going to be using
i'll show you how to set it up and again
here's the repository it is linked
within the slack channel just as a
reminder that's the place to take our
questions
that's the slack channel right there
that's the repo right there
okay let's let's do it let's get started
so
find my mouse here
okay
now i'm gonna just show you the
repository here um
and
what we have i i have a lot of
information in here the introduction of
the course but the thing i want to point
out is i've got a whole bunch of
resources at the bottom here
you know that book that i referenced
earlier which is great on graph theory
and graph algorithms
how to create a neo4j sandbox google
collab all these things we've got some
cheat sheets down here that are going to
help us out here in a minute
so the first thing that we are going to
need to do
is we're going to need to create our
graph database so what we're going to do
is we're going to go to
sandbox.neo4j.com
okay um it it might ask you for a name
and an email address just you know give
it whatever you want
okay so i'm going to give you a minute
to go fire that up
and i'd like to ask by the way while
you're getting that fired up if you are
seeing questions that are coming by in
zoom chat or you're asking questions in
zoom chat you know please please bring
them
into our slack channel but i also really
encourage especially as we get to the
coding part if people are asking
questions and you know the answer let's
make this interactive let's make this
fun it's a lot more fun when people are
helping each other out on this thing
okay so
sandbox.neo4j.com and if you're having a
hard time finding it just go to the repo
down into the helpful uh resources
section and it's that second bullet
point let me actually blow this up in
case it's hard to see over zoom so
create a neo4j sandbox
okay
so
what we're going to start with is we're
going to create a new project so click
on that new project button
okay and what we see here we've got a
whole bunch of different things that we
could use we have some pre-populated
databases here a lot of people get
started on this thing called the movies
database that's a great one for
beginners
today we're actually going to scroll
down and you see this thing that says
your own data and we're going to click
on blank sandbox so if you click there
and then you're going to go down to the
lower left and there's a blue button
here called create so we're just going
to hit create
it's going to take it a minute
okay
now we have this thing
started up we have our own free database
fired up here let's click on this little
arrow here um it's going to open up some
information for us um
one of the most important things that
we're going to see here is this thing
called connection details
okay so that's that second thing to the
second thing to the right just right of
actions
and what we have here this is we have
the ip address or the bolt url to our
sandbox we're going to be grabbing that
there a lot today um so you're going to
get to see how we work with that many
times and then we have a password here
it's going to be a randomly generated
3-word password
we have this username our username is
always going to be neo4j
okay so now just for fun click the open
button here on the right
okay
um what the open button does is it fires
up this thing called the browser you
could choose to interface with neo4j all
using this browser um we're going to be
interfacing it uh with it mostly with
python
but we're just going i'm just going to
show you a few things quickly here we're
going to populate our database from the
browser
if you are getting something like a 404
error or it's just not doing anything
like you don't see this little green
scrolling bar here
that's fine just reload your browser
okay sometimes it takes a second to fire
up now let me zoom in here
you'll see it's asking me for a username
and a password so i'm going to type my
username which is neo4j
now i'm going to go back here
and i'm going to get my password so
salvages sac dawns and i can just copy
that open gives bad gateway yes
just refresh your browser
and it can take a minute
so i'm going to copy my password just
copy and paste it into that and i'm
going to click connect
and it might take a second
okay now it says i'm connected
so let me just walk around this browser
a little bit i can click here and i can
see my database information in this case
i have no data in it it created us a
blank database
i've got no node labels no relationships
that's all well and good
okay but we need to obviously populate
our database with some useful data in
particular the cora data so let me take
you over to back to our repository and
i'll show you where we're going to find
this data here
okay so in the repository if you click
on notebooks
and then data
what i could could you stop for a bit
we're lagging behind you yeah let me let
me give you a minute great idea i'm just
gonna um just gonna give you a minute
get those databases fired up i'm gonna
grab a sip of water
while we're waiting for the browser to
spin up i'm going to show you what our
data looks like
we're going to be using csv files
there's all kinds of ways that you can
bring
your data into neo4j csvs are the
easiest way they're not always the
fastest way but it's just going to get
us started here now this is like i said
the core data set and it's frequently
convenient if you can to organize your
data in two different files or more you
would like one file that just describes
your nodes and one file that describes
your relationships now when i say
you could have multiple files if you
have multiple types of relationships
try and make a csv for each type of
relationship it's just going to save you
some time down the road let's look at
one of these data files i'm going to
pull up the nodes list here it's a
pretty big file so let's just go view
raw on this thing and the thing i want
to call to your attention
is this is the um
this right here is the csv header and
what i have are three columns i have
subject features and id now we know
these are all papers all of our nodes
are papers
um
and
what i have here there's an id which is
kind of down here
zoom in on this a touch
okay
okay so my id is is all the way down
here
it's just an integer
and then i have
neural networks is my subject for this
particular paper
and then features now what features is
um features is that vector of the um
the word vector so it's those one hot
encoded word vectors that the the owners
of the course data set already created
again i don't know what these words
correspond to but that's fine we're just
going to be running this model here and
you can see it's ones and zeros it's
very sparse i've got zeros if
you know if that particular word did not
occur i've got ones um if that one did
um so
just uh
just
those are the three things that are in
this um
in these features here
all right
um i see there are still people having
problems with the browser jim could you
tell us if you're seeing the green
scroller bar or if you're just getting
like a blank screen or a 404
just let us know what you're seeing
there
okay
and while we're waiting to hear that let
me show you what the relationships file
looks like
okay so that's coraedges.c
no errors it just takes time okay
yep just we'll just give it a minute
here
um
what we see is we've got a column called
source and a column called target okay
so you can imagine source
is citing target um
we had that graph model before that we
showed
um
so
let's uh
okay um we see that people are
refreshing their browser um
so each paper has only one
and only one subject that is correct um
makes it easy on us it's still
multi-class we still have seven
different classes but we're not doing
multi-label okay which is one of the
reasons that i chose this data set
okay so that's our data set now i'm
going to just go back to the top of the
repository here because we want to get
um
our data within to our neo4j sandbox
okay
i have created some cipher queries to do
this now let me explain what that means
neo4j and graphs tend to have their own
query languages in this case the query
language at neo4j uses is called cipher
in case you haven't noticed we like the
matrix at neo4j so a lot of our things
are named after characters in the matrix
we have a character or we have a library
called apoc
all right so what we're going to do is
we're going to click into
the
cipher queries subfolder
and there's one file here populate cora
db.c
c q ll which stands for cipherquery
language okay
now the first thing that we're going to
do it's almost like we're providing an
index for our sql database in this case
we call them constraints
okay and constraints uh what we're
telling it here create constraints we're
going to call that constraint to paper
or papers
if not exist and we've got this thing
here these round uh parentheses called
um
p
paper what does that mean that means uh
the round parentheses represent nodes
okay this is we're going to create ascii
art here actually that's how we're going
to do our graph queries
and we're going to say that the id of my
paper p so that's a variable that little
p the id is unique
okay so what that does there's i don't
have two nodes with paper id 42.
okay what i'm going to do
if you've got your browser going is i'm
just going to copy this line and paste
it
into my browser
i can click on my browser window
okay so copy and paste
and then to run it i can click this blue
arrow all the way to the right or i can
hit control enter now unfortunately
control enter works in neo4j shift enter
works in jupiter or google collab
notebooks um it is what it is okay now
it says i created one constraint on this
thing called paper so you can see now
i'm going to have these nodes node
labels called paper okay cool
now let's bring in our data we're going
to do the node list first okay so
what we're going to tell
load csv
is the command to bring in csv files
into neo4j
okay and we're going to do it row by row
we're going to call a row a line in this
case and we're for every paper
every row represents a paper
and it has a property these squiggly
braces are properties
within neo4j so it's got a property
called id
line.id just represents which column
within our csv file we're bringing in
and when we create that paper on create
set we're going to set another property
here called subject remember those
subjects were our classes the seven
classes of paper types and it's the
subject column of line
okay and i'm going to set another
property called features that um to the
line dot features those are those word
vectors
and then i'm just going to return the
count of all of those things that we
bring in okay so i'm going to copy lines
5 through 9 from the repository into my
browser
okay
i'm going to hit control enter to run it
now this is going to take a second it's
it's pulling in those csv files that i
was showing you before in this case this
was the the nodes file that we're
pulling in
i can open my little
thing over here and eventually what
we're going to see is that i'm going to
wind up with like
2708 nodes
okay there they are
okay now let's go back to our query file
we're going to load in our edge list and
this is similar to how we had um our
nodes how we created nodes but what
we're going to do is we're going to
match the source column
here and we're going to have a variable
called source
and it's of node type paper okay this is
just this is some basic cipher for you
we don't have time to get into too much
cipher i'm going to show you some
examples today
now we're going to merge a relationship
so here's how we specify a relationship
this is kind of cute so i've got my
round parentheses remember round
parentheses are nodes
and then i've got square brackets and
inside the square bracket i have the
type of my relationship so in this case
i'm calling the relationship sites
okay
and then i've got my target here now
check this out um i've created arrows so
what i'm indicating here is i have a
directed relationship from source
to target so that's kind of fun all i've
done is i've drawn a relationship
and so we're going to copy lines 12
through 17
into our browser
i'm going to hit ctrl enter
it's going to take it a second
okay so now i see that i've created
5429 relationships which is what i had
on the slides before that we should
expect and i can see over here i've got
5429 and i have a relationship called
sites
okay
cool now we have our database populated
now if you want to check that what i'm
going to do is i'm going to match a node
i'm going to match all nodes in fact i'm
not even going to specify a node type
and i'm going to match n return n
and hit enter here what's going to
happen here is we're going to get a
visualization of our graph
okay and it's not everything here it's
um
it's only going to bring in like 300 of
them because graph visualization as
you'll find out if you start getting too
many nodes and relationships and it kind
of looks like a cat's hair ball
um
so the uh this is just a portion of it
um we have brian on zoomed s so so the
curly braces are for the attribute
selection within some nodes yes and in
fact we're going to search those nodes
here in just a minute based on
attributes i'm going to show you how to
do that
okay cool we have a populated database
one of the things i'm going to tell you
is that when you do these visualizations
like i just did
it can sometimes take a fair bit of
browser memory so you might want to
close this window in order to do that
you hit this close button x that's all
the way on the upper right okay so i'm
going to close it if your browser starts
running super slow and it happens it
happens frequently just just refresh the
browser okay but we're going to get out
of the browser now we're going to go to
google colab and i'm going to give you a
minute to spin up a collab instance
you're going to go to collabs with with
a single l i'm going to copy this into
slack right here
okay so
you're going to go spin up a collab
notebook
okay so let me give you a second to get
that spun up
while those are spinning up i'll just
remind you that my zoom is having
problems with looking at chats today so
if you have questions i'd like to
encourage you to bring them over to the
slack channel instead where i can see
them the slack channel is working with
data in a connected world the power of
graph data science i know that's long go
search
for channel and just type the word
working in there and it'll come up um
so
the other thing i will tell you is that
we're going to be
bringing the repository into collab
and
what i would like you to do
i can show you the repository again here
okay it's you know if you're at github
it's cj2001
slash pi data 21 or you can also go
within the slack channel it is linked at
the top of the discussion
um
i am also going to copy it into the
channel right now just so we refresh our
memories on it
so there it is
okay
so
now
now that now that we're in collab let's
bring in the repository let me zoom in a
touch here
and now i am going to go new notebook
okay
okay
i am going to say um
let's see
where did it go
um
this is silly it usually gives me a link
to bring it in from github
okay
okay that's what we do
we are going to click file
upload notebook
okay so click file and upload notebook
and we're going to select github here
okay now here's where you're going to
need that url
last number was missing oh yep sorry i
didn't copy in the whole thing thanks
telling you um okay so we're going to
copy in
github
dot com
cj 2001
slash pi data 2021
okay
click enter and it shows me all of the
notebooks within my repository
what i recommend you do just so we don't
have to type the repository back in
every time
i recommend that you open the notebooks
in new windows using that that square
with an arrow button all the way on the
right the first notebook that we're
going to open is called intro to cipher
okay
so
um these uh do we need to create an
account on google collab and login to
create the notebook yeah you're going to
need a google account
um
[Music]
so now what we're going to do the
notebooks are all available we're going
to have to pick up the pace just a
little bit here so we can get through
all the notebooks they're all in the
repository and they all have a bunch of
comments in them so um first thing that
we need to do is we need to install the
neo4j 4j driver the python driver so i'm
just going to click the run button right
here uh-oh the notebook was not authored
by google okay run anyway
okay so this is going to take a second
now what you'll see um in the repository
i keep the outputs of all of the cells
um or i try to and the reason for that
is so that you can see what the output
is supposed to look like so if you're
not driving along right now that's
totally fine
you can look at the notebooks and see
what we're going to get okay so it's
installed the driver and now i just want
to use pandas and we're going to import
this thing called graph database from
that neo4j
python package you're just going to give
it a run cool
all right now we're not going to worry
too much about this this is a class that
i use to make the connection if you work
with sql like sql alchemy or anything
like that this is going to look pretty
similar like how you would use cursors
within those packages
i just created this thing here we're not
going to worry about too much about what
it says okay now we actually need to
connect to our database so
we're going to go back to this ui here
which has our bolt url and our password
okay and i'm going to copy the bolt url
okay i'm going to go back here i'm going
to put it into this variable called uri
okay
and i'm going to go back and i'm going
to get my password
copy it
and i'm going to paste it into the
variable here pwd
and using those two things this is how
we're going to establish our connection
to neo4j so i'm going to run that cell
gave me no errors so yay i think we've
made a connection but we're going to
we're going to check we're just going to
check and
this here is a cipher query i'm going to
match all of my nodes remember around
parentheses are nodes and i'm going to
return
the count of those nodes i've received a
question can i know where can i show
where to find the uri and the password
absolutely
so this is sandbox.neo4j.com
and you need to click on connection
details
okay
and that's where you get your bolt url
which we call uri within neo4j
um
so you're going to hit the copy button
and paste that into the notebook and
then the password also we're going to
copy and paste that into the notebook
okay
back to our counting query match n
return count event so this is going to
just tell us how many nodes are within
our database and we want to make sure
that it says
2708
which it did so that means we know we're
connected to a populated database
okay
let's look at now the
what information is available on our
nodes okay so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to match a node here
and i'm telling it that it's of node
type paper that's colon
paper here it's just how it happens in
cipher i'm going to give it a variable
name p so p is of node label type paper
i'm going to return one node okay that's
that limit one here and what i get here
is i get this thing called a record and
it's got properties remember the curly
braces are properties
okay and those are long vectors they're
more than 400 dimensional well they're
1400 dimensional one for every word
within our vocabulary
okay so i can see i have an id now i'm
going to point out here my id is an
integer but we imported it as a string
okay so when we query things based on id
number we want to make sure that we use
a quote to indicate that it's string and
then i have a subject for this paper of
neural networks cool
okay
kind of weird as python folks to look at
this record type i'd rather look at it
in a data structure than i know better
so i'm going to do
i'm going to return it as a panda's data
frame now let me explain this query i'm
going to match a paper called p
and i'm going to return its id as a
column that i'm going to name id i'm
going to return the subject as a column
that's labeled subject
and the features those word vectors
i'm going to return as a column called
features and i'm going to return five of
them now this is coming back kind of as
a dictionary um so i'm just going to
create a data frame out of the
dictionary of those queries here so
let's give that a run and here i have a
pandas data frame now so that's cool
um can you show sorry we've done that
question just as a reminder where you
find the uri and password is in
sandbox.com click on connection details
and get this bolt ip address and here's
your password
okay
now let's calculate
how many instances there are of each
class now i've already told you that
there are seven but i'm going to show
you how to do that so i'm going to match
all of my papers
and remember those papers each have
subjects okay so i have some subject
that's like neural networks or
reinforcement learning things like this
i'm going to return the distinct values
of those subjects and then i'm going to
count how many papers had those subjects
so if you if you've worked with sql this
should look somewhat similar to sql i'm
going to return it as a data frame
okay
um actually let me give a
head of 10 here so we can see them all
okay
so um let's see so cypher seems to be
the neo4j native language i imagine
there are some resources or tutorials to
get familiar with the syntax absolutely
if you go into the readme for the
repository there's links at the bottom
and there's a ton of cipher references
there there's also classes online neo4j
has this thing called graph academy or
just go to youtube and search for like
cipher lessons and stuff like that
there's tons of classes out there um
subject are words and the matrix is the
occurrence and the papers yes um the
subject is uh they labeled um this paper
is about neural networks this paper is
about genetic algorithms so somebody
labeled that um
and the um
the matrix is the occurrence and the
papers yes so that it's the occurrence
of these 1400 words um so sometimes
those words occur and sometimes they
don't occur it's just the abstract it's
not the whole papers
but yeah
so here i've got my subjects and i can
see what my distribution is on how many
papers are in our data set of those
subjects now you see this is fairly
imbalanced we've got 800 papers on
neural networks we all only have 180 on
rule learning guess what we're just
going to go with it okay cool so let's
calculate in degree now what the in
degree tells us is how many papers are
citing my target paper so higher in
degree means that it's been cited more
times so these would be kind of like the
influential papers within the data set
so let me show you the cipher for that
um so i'm going to get my papers and
i've got a size thing now here let's
look at what's inside the parentheses
here i'm saying some node i didn't even
call it anything it doesn't even have a
variable it has the relationships of
sight to something that we're calling p
okay and the size of that is how many
times that relationship exists to p
okay we're going to call that in degree
we're going to return the id the subject
and the in degree and we're just going
to order it by decreasing in degree
we're going to get five of them so these
are going to be our top five papers
okay
and here they are there's a paper id of
35 in genetic algorithms it has
166 citations when i was a professor i
would have loved to have seen that for
my h index score okay
so we can look at in degree that way and
i'm going to cruise through these things
i apologize we're going to go kind of
fast i encourage you to review these
notebooks in the repository you know
afterwards if this is of interest to you
okay now somebody talked about
matching based on properties and here's
where we're going to do it okay we're
going to match
some paper it's citing some other paper
which we're going to call target and i'm
going to set where target id the id of
that target is paper number 114 but
you'll notice i have quotes here because
remember we brought it in as a string
and not as an integer into our database
and then i'm going to return the id
of p1 that's the papers that cite my
target
okay so let's give that a run
okay
so i have
all of these papers are the ones that
are citing um
my target paper of 114 okay cool
now here's one thing i'm excited to show
you this is for you sequel fans out
there and what we're going to do is
we're going to find how many papers are
within three hops of a target source
okay
in this case we're going to use paper
114 again so how many papers are within
three hops think of this like the six
degrees of kevin bacon game how many
people are within six degrees of kevin
bacon and um what i get here um
is this look at this this is fun i
reverse the direction of my arrow i can
do that i'm just drawing things okay and
now i'm not even going to specify the
relationship type i'm using this thing
square brackets of relationships and
what i am saying here with this asterisk
and then 1.3 is any relationship between
one and three hops okay
think for a second about how hard it is
to write that sql query it will take you
a lot of joins
but it's also slow graph traversal is
slow when you're writing multiple joins
sql is slow with multiple joins
how slow this graph traversal here is
somewhere between three and five orders
of magnitude faster and look how simple
it is it's just a few lines here so
we're gonna run it
okay and now i have how many uh these
are all of my
targets
my target subject is a paper and
reinforcement learning we knew that
before this paper here as a subject
source
of reinforcement learning as well and
all of the papers within this query
would be within three hops so that's
pretty cool
all right let's move on let's get into
some data science here um i want you to
go back to
um
our thing here where we were importing
github and we're going to start with
quora word embedding so what this is
going to do click on that um pop out to
a new tab button
okay i'm going to close the other one um
okay so i have this thing called cora
word embeddings and i'm going to import
my notebook and while i do that
let me tell you what we're going to do
here is we're going to take those word
vectors that cora provided us with those
one hot encoded vectors and we're going
to create a machine learning model it's
just going to be super simple it's not
optimized for anything we're just going
to create a support vector classifier
we're going to use just normal scikit
learn for it and see how well can we do
in terms of accuracy we're going to
measure the accuracy of our ability to
predict one of those seven classes based
on the word vectors now remember i
didn't create those word vectors they
might not be very well optimized but
we're just going to get an idea of what
happens here okay so my
my driver package is installed got a
bunch of packages here that are just
kind of traditional python packages just
import those i've got that same class
that i used before
and we're going to make our connection
now again we're going to see this a few
times we're going to go back to
sandbox.neo4j.com
and we're going to get our ip address
here so i'm going to copy that
and i'm going to paste it in here okay
i'm going to go and i'm going to grab my
password
i'm going to paste it in
okay now we're going to make our
connection and we're just going to count
nodes just to make sure that we properly
made the connection you should see two
thousand seven hundred eight nodes here
okay i'm going to use this opportunity
to stop and suggest that if you have
questions bring them into the slack
channel which is working with data in a
connected world the power of graph data
science
okay because i can't see for reasons of
unknown i can't see zoom chat from my
computer right now it's kind of
embarrassing
okay now um we have some data formatting
to do our goal is to get um
numpy arrays out of our graph database
and um you know we were storing things
in strings before if you actually look
those word vectors are stored as strings
so um we have a little bit of cleaning
to do on our data coming out of neo4j
it's pretty straightforward though we're
going to create a data frame just like
we did before um
you know so we're going to get the id of
the paper
here
we're going to get the subject of the
paper and the features are those word
embeddings and we're going to put that
all into a data frame
and i i have to play some games here to
get the
the features in out of
string of list into just list and then
i'm going to create a new column here
called embeddings
and that's just turning our
word vectors into a numpy array
okay and then i'm going to create if
you're familiar with scikit-learn they
create x and y and they use capital x
and little y that's all i'm doing here
is i'm creating my capital x and my
little y so that's all these functions
are doing here they're just little
helper functions
okay now we're going to create our model
okay so here's our ml model
and again this is not optimized this is
done just for the sake of demonstration
and simplicity here
we're going to do a five-fold validation
so k-fold validation
we already we're going to pull in our
data frame and we're going to create
our x and y variables based on that data
frame
okay and then we're going to do a train
test split this is just our normal
you know scikit-learn train test split
and i'm giving a test size of 25
you know that could be anything i chose
a smaller one just from the standpoint
of this isn't a big data set so i want
to be able to get a fair bit of training
in on it um okay and here's our
classifier we're using a support vector
machine cl classifier um
and this class weight thing says to
scikit learn try to balance the classes
if you can okay and then we're going to
get our accuracy score back um and we'll
get the mean score and then we're going
to plot our confusion matrix just so we
get some sort of nice visual back and
we're going to give this a run it's
going to take a second oh that's just
that's just creating the function the
actual modeler um i'm deliberately not
showing you the next line because i
don't want to give away the surprise
okay but let's run the modeler
click on the run button
okay and this is going to take a second
um
[Music]
you know if you get an accuracy back
here of 50 percent that means that a
chip flip a chimp flipping a coin can do
better so we want to see an accuracy
better than 50
on any of our machine learning models
okay
let's see
still running that's that's okay these
these sometimes take a minute
um
we're used to that
while it does i'm going to remind you of
the github repository it's got the
slides in it it's it has all of the data
it has all of the cipher queries it's
got the notebooks
and it also has a link of helpful
references at the bottom
so
any minute now google
any minute runtime was 58 seconds okay
um
in some of the in the case uh that we
have
limited time because we've got a little
more than 15 minutes left i might just
cruise through some of these notebooks
and not actually run them okay
but we'll do what we can here okay so i
see that we have a mean accuracy of
about 72
here's my confusion matrix you know it's
not bad
it's not great not bad but you know we
haven't done any optimization on the the
word embeddings or on the actual um
support classifier model
okay now let's do this with a graph
so what we're going to do is we're going
to go back to we're going to create a
new
collab notebook okay and we're going to
open now quora graph embeddings i'm
going to open it in a new tab
and close this other one just so we
don't confuse google too much
okay and like before we're going to
bring in our neo4j package
okay
and it's going to be just like before
um
i'm going to bring in all the same
functions um one additional one because
we're going to visualize these
embeddings here in a second
okay so let's import our packages
we're going to import our connection
okay we get to make our connection again
so i'm back at sandbox.neo4j.com
i copy my bolt url
as uri here
my password and go get that
okay
here's my password um it should say that
i have
2708 notes okay now i'm just going to
click through these things here and this
is all the same stuff as before
i just want to get the modeler starting
to run okay now in this case let me show
you what we're doing
i'm going to get an error here yep
i forgot
to do an important step
okay
if you go back to the repository into
that cipher queries thing here we have
to do something very important we are
going to create what's called an in
memory graph this is a graph projection
where i'm telling the graph data science
library what to do now what's the graph
data science library or gds gds is a
built-in library to neo4j to do all of
our data science calculations so we're
talking about some of the things that we
could do before like um louvain
clustering we could do node similarity
betweenness centrality all of that all
of that is built into gds in fact
there's uh
more than 60 different data science
functions that are built into here but
in order to make gds run what we are
going to do is we are going to create
this thing called an in-memory graph now
what the in-memory graph does is it
takes a portion whatever portion we tell
it to of our database and it puts it
into another space it's a very efficient
memory space where it's going to do the
calculations now
one of the things that we have to do is
tell it which nodes and which
relationships
we have a monopartite graph meaning we
have all the same types of nodes and
relationships and we're going to use the
whole graph now if you're not using a
monopartite graph you need to think
about how you're going to do this a lot
of the gds algorithms want a monopartic
graph so you're going to need to think
about how can i collapse my
my my multi-part type graph into a
monopartic graph that's that's a more
advanced subject it's beyond the scope
of today we have a nice simple graph
that we're going to create one of these
projections of now the other thing i
will tell you is that
a lot of gds algorithms want an
undirected graph and if you recall our
direct our graph was actually directed
so we're going to tell we're going to
tell gds to turn it into an undirected
graph which basically means we should
see double the number of relationships
because what it's going to do is it's
going to if i have a relationship this
way it's going to duplicate it going the
other way okay now here lines 20 through
28 within our cipher uh the populate
core db
file in the cipher query subdirectory
this is how we create the in memory
graph so let me show you the syntax here
i'm creating a graph with a name called
quora okay so i give the graph a name
and then i'm going to tell it what
relationship types now this could be a
list of different i'm sorry these are
the node types this could be a list of
different node types but we're not doing
it that way because we only have one
node type in this graph okay and that
node type is called paper
okay i also could bring in multiple
relationship types we only have one it's
called sites now i'm providing a
dictionary here that tells there are
certain keywords that you can use such
as orientation and orientation has a
value of undirected um
how to do this is actually you can find
this more in my bite-sized neo4j for
data scientists which is linked in the
repository readme but let's just give
this a run really quick so i'm going to
copy lines 20 to 28 and i'm going to
paste it into my browser
okay
and this is going to create my in memory
graph for us give them a second
okay so here it is you can see i've
doubled my number of relationships as i
predicted that we would
but now we're going to use that
in-memory graph to do all of our
calculations on okay
um
one of the things that we're going to do
the most important thing we're going to
do is create our graph embeddings and
we're going to use this thing called
fast rp
okay this is a very simple graph
embedding technique i was talking before
how we're just going to randomly hop
around the graph
okay and
and as we hop we're going to see what
other nodes we hit on these hops we're
going to do it a few times and we're
going to average them together and
that's what creates our embedding let me
show you what they look like when we do
that so i'm just going to copy lines 31
to 38 into our browser
okay
one of the things i want to point out
remember i said that gds brings things
into its own space it also creates its
own ids that don't correspond to
anything physical anything that we would
recognize so um what we need to do for
today is we're going to pull out
our um this is bringing us out of that
gds identification into our normal
identification so um we always gds
always returns this thing called node id
and embedding and so i'm going to say
give me the actual id that we're
interested in that's our normal id space
that could be a little confusing there
okay so here now what i have is i have
my paper id and i've got something that
looks just like my embeddings from
before it's not one hot encoded like we
had for our word vectors okay but but
this is this is how we get our graph
embeddings so now i'm going to run the
line that failed here and what i'm doing
is i'm telling my modeler to give me a
256 dimensional vector
okay so we're going to let that run and
let me show you here
we created our embeddings before
okay
um
did we create them
uh
okay here's actually where we're
creating them is this function create
embeddings um
and i'm calling the same function as
before you'll notice though that i'm
calling this thing called write rather
than stream before i called stream and
what stream does is it just outputs the
results to the browser screen but when i
use write it writes whatever its
calculation is to the nodes
okay now there are all kinds of
hyperparameters for all of the things in
gds i'm picking a few here don't worry
about what they are if you're interested
you can go into the gds docs and read up
more about them i've also written some
medium posts on them
but what i the big one here is i'm
telling it invention
embedding dimension of 256
and i'm telling it it's going to write a
property so those nodes are getting a
new property called fast rpm bettings
okay and then we're going to go through
all the same processes as before and
here's the result that i get now you
remember when we did this with word
embeddings we got an accuracy of about
72 percent but here check it out i got
like 83 and i haven't even optimized my
graph embeddings that's pretty wild okay
that's pretty cool all i did was took
advantage of the relationships between
these different nodes these different
papers so that's in my view pretty cool
okay now what we're going to do is we're
going to actually look at these
embeddings and see if they make sense
we had to map our classes before into
numbers so just um if you're interested
here's what these numbers correspond to
in this um
and what we're about to see here i'm
going to just create a normal tsne plot
of our data
let's give that a run
okay
it's going to take a second here and
again
i'm telling it that we're going to
create
a 256 dimensional we're creating our
embeddings we're creating our x and y
and then we're throwing those through
tsne okay and um
and we're just gonna see what they look
like now ideally what we should see
if we do some sort of dimensionality
reduction like tsne or pca we should see
clusters we should see our nodes like
all of all of one node should be
clustered together and all of another
node should be clustered in a different
space and you know in a really cool
world they're separated by a lot but
let's see what they look like here
okay
all right
i want to zoom out a little bit just so
we can see this a little see the whole
thing
okay so what i have here are my red
nodes you can see are kind of scattered
all around now i'm going to come back to
why that is in a second
i've got purple nodes class 5 and they
seem to be clustered pretty well
together what's class 5 class 5 is
genetic algorithms
okay
what do i have here in these lime green
ones lime green is class two what is
class two class two is reinforcement
learning now if you think about this
these are some pretty specific sub
disciplines so it would make sense that
their papers would be citing each other
but what about xero which is neural
networks those are the red ones well
neural networks that's pretty big broad
category right so
a lot of a lot of papers are going to
cite the big neural network papers
because a lot of these other types of
machine learning will talk about neural
networks so it would make sense then
that the cluster associated with neural
networks would be spread out over a lot
of places and overlap
so so when i look at a plot like this i
i can kind of graph what it's saying
here you know this makes intuitive sense
if you think about what the underlying
data is okay so that's cool let's do one
more thing can we overrun oh we can
overrun a few minutes if you want okay
well we're not going to actually run
this next one because it takes this is
the last notebook and it takes a lot of
time so let's see if we can make it
through but thank you tanya okay last
one we're going to open here is called
cora tune embeddings okay so any data
scientist is going to want to take some
time to really you know once you have a
model developed you're going to want to
tune the hyper parameters of that model
and i'm going to show you how i'm not
actually going to run this today
but you you can run it in your notebook
just fine okay now we're going to be
using a library called apptuna if you're
not familiar with optuna um if you want
to win a kaggle channel challenge you
should be using optuna to tune your
hyperparameters lots of these winners do
okay
so again we install our usual packages
including uptune and we make our
connection to the database okay just
like before we create our x and y
variables we have our model and again
just for the graphs just for the sake of
comparison i'm still using that same
really basic support vector classifier
model i haven't changed anything so i'm
trying to do as much of an
apples-to-apples comparison as possible
here we return the accuracy score just
as we did before
but now um we've got this thing called
an objective and this is how optuna
works is you create a test
you do many trials through this test and
optuna has a way of mathematically
trying to play around with your
different hyper parameters to optimize
what you tell it to optimize so in this
case i am optimizing four hyper
parameters associated with fast rp
and you can go and look up what these
things are but i'm optimizing the
embedding dimension i'm optimizing some
weights
normalization strength
and
let's see we're telling it to do this
right here
okay so whatever
whatever value it chose to try out for
these things is getting thrown into fast
rp writing it to the database now here
i'm saying that we're going to try
integers for embeddings between 32 and
512 so it's going to try embedding
dimensions of like 32
somewhere to 512 and it'll pop around a
bunch
okay here's where i actually run my
study i give it some initial parameters
just kind of heat it up before it goes
warm it up
okay and so it'll run a whole bunch of
trials this is what it looks like and it
i told it that it needed to optimize
based on accuracy and i told it that it
should maximize accuracy okay so we
could scroll down here and here's what
we get once it found what the optimal
parameters were
this is what it looks like you get this
plot each blue point here is showing you
here's what my accuracy was for this
particular run
and what we see the best value that we
get of accuracy is 86
okay that's 15
greater than what we got when we are
using the word embeddings and it's like
three percent greater than what we got
without tuning the embeddings
that's pretty impressive
okay so then i can also look at which
parameters dominated that solution and
by far the one that dominated was the
embedding dimension you'll want to
tinker around with this for your given
model there's all kinds of other ways
within gds that you can create graph
embeddings and they all have different
sensitivities to different
hyperparameters they all have different
hyper parameters so
so that's cool
we can visualize those embeddings just
like we did before looks kind of similar
because you know those hyper parameters
didn't change much from what i gave it
originally so yay
um okay it's time to wrap up so let's go
back to our slides and here's what we
learned today we learned why graphs and
why why not just sql now i am not going
to tell you that graphs are the end-all
and be-all and the only way that you
should do things okay some sql can get
you some very good results but think
about
how you might have relationships within
your data because you can absolutely
take advantage of those now one of the
things you want to think about though is
that
this is going to work best if your data
is very tightly connected so like i have
a lot of nodes if i have two nodes over
here and two nodes over here and three
nodes up here and and whatnot those
random skips around the graph are not
going to work it's going to be kind of
like ping pong this node this node this
node this node so those embeddings are
not going to be very meaningful
how do you know if you have a graphy
problem we talked about lots of sql
joins um we talked about some graph
theory we did some machine learning in
some code and then i said we're going to
wrap up
so
i want to remind you of the two key
concepts the two things that if you took
nothing else away from today i want you
to remember so the first one
was that it can be good to break that
assumption about the rows being
uncorrelated okay um
we have seen examples of that today
where the individual data points are
correlated and our assumptions our
machine learning assumptions about the
independence of each data point were
broken
second
modeling relationships can result in
models that are less noisy think about
that we had nlp is very noisy it's hard
that's why you have nlp experts out
there but the graph the relationships
between those two papers or those
multiple papers is not ambiguous it is
significantly less noisy um when we
looked at this problem that way okay i
want to just say thank you for attending
we are at time it is 30 after the hour
this is how you can find me on the
internet is through twitter
and i also post a lot on medium about
the concepts that you saw today all of
those things are linked on the github
repository and with that we're going to
bring it to a close so thank you
everyone for attending thank you tanya
thank you the organizers of pi data i
hope you got something out of today so
enjoy the rest of the conference and
we'll see out there